Pippa Middleton is a married woman the  33 year old socialite and her longtime  love and hedge fund manager James  Matthews tied the knot on Saturday May  20th it's wonderful the couple first  started dating in 2012 and became  engaged in July of 2016  Kate Middleton's little sis had plenty  of Royals in attendance including her  big sis and hubby Prince William Pippa's  niece Princess Charlotte was a  bridesmaid while nephew Prince George  served as pageboy I think it's really  impressive a source close to the  beautiful bride dish to ET in April just  how she was preparing for the big day  well she's been working out about four  or five times a week working with a  personal trainer at a gym near her home  in Chelsea and doing Pilates  [Music]